well hello everyone producer Pat here
filling in for David today at least for
now at least for the first part of the
show David is of course at home resting
he had appendicitis had to get surgery
yesterday early in the morning he should
be back next week he's in good spirits
he's feeling okay but he does feel as
though a part of him is missing which
does make sense after getting ones
appendix taken out but we have to get
into the news because the news waits for
no one
and what I want to talk about today is
how Trump held a joint press conference
with the finish president Selina NIST oh
they talked about the normal stuff at
first trade security economics they both
had their prepared statements but
everyone realizes that it's sort of a
charade because when it's time to ask
questions no reporters actually going to
ask about us finished relations they're
gonna ask about the topics of the day
they're gonna ask about the things that
they want to ask about and right now the
topic on everyone's mind is impeachment
and the call that President Trump had
with ukrainian president back in july
and really at this point it's not even a
question over whether the president
committed a crime it's more a question
about how many crimes did President
Trump commit and what were the severity
of those crimes and are we as a people
going to hold him accountable either by
way of Congress impeaching Trump or by
way of the voters voting him out in 2020
so all that stuff is of course still
left to be decided but the press
conference was a total mess it was Trump
going on and on about how this is just
the latest witch hunt and how everyone's
out to get him he talked about shifty
Adam Schiff Adam Schiff is of course the
head of the u.s. intelligence committee
in the house and you know calling a
Jewish person shifty definitely has some
anti-semitic undertones but that's the
sort of thing that we can kind of come
to expect from Trump at this point but
what I found most peculiar of all was
how Trump would try to be alpha over the
Finnish president at times but and then
other times he would hide behind the
Finnish President so like what would
happen would be Trump would get a
question he would ramble on and on take
control of the floor not let the Finnish
president talk and then whenever he
would get a question from a reporter
that he didn't like he would say why
aren't you asking the Finnish president
something we
have a guest here it would be rude not
to ask the Finnish president something
so let me show you one example of that
and then we'll come back ok what's your
second question just but you shouldn't
be answering asking two questions well
you're gonna want to answer me a favor
you ask ask one of the I will finish the
one you want to ask John Square ask one
of the Finnish president can I come back
to you because I think you'll want to
talk later sure well it sounds like it
might be a good question let me see if I
like the question go ahead there may be
for the first time in three years I'll
have a good question and I'll love it
and then here's Trump doing the exact
same thing again sprinkled in this time
with some fake news this is all a hoax
stuff that we've come to expect from
Trump the question sir was what did you
want president Solinsky to do about
President Vice President Biden and his
son Hunter yeah it was just a follow up
of what I just asked you sir we have the
president of Finland ask him a question
I have one for my just wanted to follow
up on the one that I asked you which did
you hear what do you want you hear me
yes ask him a question I will but my
even you a long answer ask this
gentleman a question don't be rude no
sir I don't want to be rude I just
wanted you to have a chance to answer
the question that I asked everything
it's a whole hoax and you know who's
playing into the hoax people like you
and the fake news media that we have in
this country and I say in many cases the
corrupt media because you corrupt much
of the media in this country is not just
fake it's corrupt and you have some very
fine people two great journalists great
reporters but it to a large extent it's
corrupt and it's fake
ask the president of Finland to question
place okay I'll move on now mr.
president in your opening remarks you
said to President Trump that you had
been to some museums today and that you
respected the u.s. democracy and
encouraged him to continue it are you
concerned that that's not happening and
my second question to you sir is the WTO
rule today in favor of the United States
saying that the United States can now
impose tariffs on European goods because
of illegal subsidies against Airbus oh
is a big win for the United States right
it was you never had wins with other
presidents did you but we're having a
lot of wins at the WTO
that started I think 10 or 15 years ago
excuse me
it Windsor now because they think I
don't like the WTO and they want to make
sure I'm happy because all of those
countries were ripping off the United
States for many years they know that I'm
wise to it we've had a lot of wins this
was a 7 billion dollar win not bad but
nice for the question sir is if you're
concerned that the president I
absolutely loved Anastos body language
there like he's pointing trying to get a
word in and it's not like he's being
like a total pushover or anything but
he's being deferential and I think that
makes all the sense in the world one
because you know he's a guest in a
foreign country but I think it more so
has to do with the fact that Minister
realizes that Trump has power over him
the u.s. is of course a much bigger
country than Finland and if Trump is
upset with their leader he could
retaliate against them and he's done
that before with smaller countries we
saw him temporarily pull aid from
Ukraine so maybe the Finnish president
doesn't want a similar thing to happen
to him of course the u.s. doesn't give
Finland financial aid but you know
something something similar could of
course happen so this was the press
conference it's a total gong show but
hey that's the that's the America that
we live in in 2019 today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom /
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blankets it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get
the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month
that's be li NK is t.com /p a que ma n